these are scary times and as a parent I
think I feel a little more pressure but
imagine being pregnant during a pandemic
I know there's many other mothers like
me that are wondering like how do we how
do we be affected in this time and then
like a daily one slow and slow and I
keep trying to remind myself that people
have had babies and much worse and much
more intense conditions that's been
killing us a little bit fears and
unknowns that's what many moms-to-be are
struggling with Ciara wore face masks
and had to FaceTime with husband Russell
Wilson while she got an ultrasound when
it's time to deliver what is that gonna
be like as for Katy Perry I think of a
things to be grateful for Katy and
Orlando Bloom are channeling any stress
into focusing on getting their home baby
girl ready a source tells us quote being
in quarantine has been good for Katy
because it's making her slow down and
rest I'm in my parked car because it's
my place where I can be by myself good
for her and maybe a reminder to all of
us sometimes it's okay to slow down
first-time dad to be Travis Stork from
the doctors and his wife Paras are
expecting a baby boy how are you doing
doing okay you know it's it's been a
little rough because Paris is seven
months pregnant and we had a water leak
so we're uh we've had a lot of workers
in and out of the house she's doing the
best we can to protect her pregnant
women have a compromised immune system
luckily we've already learned so much
more about this virus if you need to go
to the hospital you know we now have a
much better understanding in terms of
how to take care of Travis's tips for
navigating uncertainty amid a quarantine
baby boom number one stay fit like Kevin
Hart and his expectant wife amico
number two stay occupied not worried
Travis keeps busy hosting a podcast from
his home first-time mom to be Megan
McCain co-host the view from hers when
her fur to be in studio with all of you
but my doctor is just I went to many
recommended against it can I see the
bump the doubly blessed bella twins are
following rule number three keep loved
ones close for support but not too close
you don't let any other family members
[Music]